yes you absolutely can because the
question is why is it a quote bad habit
the question is like in what way does
this quote habit impair you if you're an
investor and you spend all of your money
that would be a bad habit it would
impair you from actually investing right
but if you were an Olympic lifter
there's plenty of foreign Olympic
lifters that smoke between sets because
nicotine's a stimulant and so how are we
defining bad and so I think that the
Habit that you're defining is bad you
have to clearly tie to how it stops you
from doing the input that you need for
your path to success and so these are
not like binary yes or no's it's against
what goal and to what degree and so can
you decrease it to the degree that it's
not a huge detractor then sure and maybe
if you do that long term you'll be able
to stick with your thing for a longer
period of time because you balance some
of the things that you enjoy in life